yeah welcome to this video round 10 for
this year's Tata Steel tournament in a
long tournament but we are nearing the
finish line and I'm going to start with
a Dutch tool yeah exactly then Vinny
against the onigiri the first game of
today that i'm going to show and we have
a groom thought to switch on the sound
is rotating we don't have a green felt
we have a sloth i'm sorry this is but
it's an understandable mistake we see
this we'll see later wine queen c to g
six hours laughs with quincy to which
covers the pole and geary place g6 which
is a good response to the smooth the
main move is actually to take on c four
by g six is good as well we should their
form 5073 very logical white develops
his pieces and now has c4 covered with
the bishop so it's a natural cover for
the spawn here black has a couple of
options Bishop f5 for example on night a
six-hour moves that are possible gear
ojala played an interesting movie played
35 so losing a temper with the sea pawn
this means we have now a theoretical
position from the goon felt this is some
grammar mistake comes from from the
gruene fought with white having this
Quincy to move as an extra move so the
tempo that black lost is Quincy to the
question is is this a useful move and it
seems that it really doesn't help white
much why did took on c5 which is some
the logical reply wider doesn't really
want like to take him on deform and give
him an isolated pawn so why it takes and
now we need five
which initiated this counter play along
this diagonal using this pin so a
possible idea would be as he takes d5
night XD 5 and black has strong play
oops again see three so I'm white
shouldn't take and this is just the same
as in the GU felt only then white would
play a rook see one and in fact you play
brooksy one year as well the sir but
this seems to help like quite a bit
maybe it is better to go Rudy one but
all in all this liner looks fairly
decent for black I had a quick look
through my database after this game and
it looks quite decent so this setup can
be a good idea against Quincy to yak
with Roxy one was played and now black
just developed and the question is what
should white play now in fact he doesn't
have so great moves in this position I'm
again taking some in this case even
though better for black then and then
the position before what what exactly
should you play if you cannot take it's
not so easy he decided to play a queenly
to and actually force the the coming
sequence takes on c4 Bishop c4 in Quincy
five and Queenie to covering the bishop
and now the funny thing is we again have
transposed to the groom felt but now
with black having the extra move and
this actually is a huge difference the
difference is if white would have the
extra move like in the groove out then
he would have castled alrighty and with
white and not having canceled with c 9
a-5 which is a good move bishop needs to
retreat was attacked and no 95 and of
course this wouldn't be a problem at all
if white
Castle then he could simply take on d5
and now you are on check this is very
embarrassing the rook is simply
unprotected one cannot take on d5 and
black is threatening to capture both the
bishop to damage the pawn structure and
gain the bishop and also take here and
one white castled and now black took on
c3 which is better also then taking on
f4 and now we see that black is opening
her spinner yeah a big success I would
say he managed to damage whites pawn
structure is gone a week sepan blacks
got this great room for bishop it's got
free development so like certainly am
has a slight advantage here very good
opening result Bishop d7 to our logical
putting pressure on the big porn and
Bishop on a form takes away squares like
this on c2 on b3 and it simply gets out
of the way though so that loop d8 would
have some influence Queen B to the only
problem really isn't it all looks very
nice for black but it's not so easy to
make any concrete progress here he
played rook to d8 we should be to this
intense bishop f3 getting some play on
b7 also be five of course will
threatened the d3 Bishop Rogers was just
an unprotected piece h5 yeah this is
some fairly typical move from intending
maybe sometimes to play h4 gaining a
temp or even attacking the bishop when
when the pawn is not non hanging it also
gives some some lift for blacks King so
it's a pretty pretty good move very
often this flag poles Queen B form
now I think exactly this is a really
critical position here Aguirre decided
to take on d4 which initiates a longer
sequence of exchanges I'm not a long
sequence but it simply changes the
position a lot he had the alternative
and I think a good alternative and
taking on before takes here and then
capturing oops then capturing on default
the point is if white would take here
then knight c6 is very good for black
you just went to clear pond so I'm white
wouldn't take on default by take on a
five and now I'm like we'll probably
retreat fisherman f3 Bishop c6 and this
is some very comfortable positions of
like those pawns are still some good
week and you have a little bit more
activity on those open file so black has
a distinct advantage if it is enough to
to play for win it's hard to say but
this was a good alternative he took on
deform takes on a for this was it's the
transformation that is not happening
back winning upon and this is certainly
what tempted him to do this however
check we look at this is a pretty force
um it seems that this piece
configuration is some it's rather
peculiar because it's difficult to
improve those pieces because they are
tied together in some really unlucky
fashion let's say queen d7 this was
played before and age for the normal
moves what does black do now to improve
it's really difficult you cannot really
this night is stuck on the on the air on
the rim night v 7s hanging at c-6 hangs
the rook um you cannot move the bishop
you cannot move this pawn with free
would be be a bad move freely taking
Roxie to so good for what even and it's
it's difficult to make a move
I think the the best chance was actually
night to see form which she didn't play
and this intends to reroute the night or
here he didn't didn't play that
surprisingly i think it's relatively
obvious idea to play this he played the
move ruge f8 which looks a bit strange
but ok this group was always hanging he
wants to move the night now our Bishop
f4 96 27 and it's still very difficult
for black to move anything you need to
be cautious Bishop f3 as a serious
threat yeah tiara decided to simply
trade this down to a draw acknowledging
that you cannot really play for when
probably you really can't this Bishop f3
is very annoying I think you missed the
snide c4 chance um here you played the
queen bee 6 and this trades down two to
nothing attacking here yeah counter take
on a six yeah it's a it's simply a
longer sequence that leads to a dead
drop yeah and this is so so drawn that
pretty much everyone would manage to
draw him um yeah I'm not too exciting
this game but thank Gary miss them some
chance here maybe to press for more and
this opening is interesting if you play
this laughs and someone is playing this
Queen c2 against you you actually have a
good alternative to other lines in what
gear plate yet it's also very forced
after g6 white almost always plays
Bishop f4 this is the idea of Queen c2
and this is completely illogical and not
see 45 and black seems to have a decent
game some good opening
tip maybe two to check out alright so
let's go to the next game are only on
against one how never playing c4 he's
mixing up his first moves c4d 493 but
his plate as he for earlier in this
tournament with a successful again here
and one how goes 45 and we have this
reversed Sicilian four nights g3 and now
the funny move 94 which really doesn't
look yeah it looks a bit weird because
well why is black moving this piece
again and why is he giving away the e5
on the point is if white would take
which is um yeah probably bad then
Queenie seven is played and the first
and simple ideas of white would secure
the night then this is a whoops
technique very quick check made so white
cannot move the night really he needs to
protect it this way and then d 6 is
played 93 and let's say Bishop f5 just
one possibility and whites position is
completely em yeah it completely under
Monell so do you ever get your stuff
developed yet black has a big air big
advantage prolly already with at least a
very good compensation so white cannot
take this and ok well why just place
Bishop g2 chant like takes and ok you
can ask yourself why it's like losing
all those moves but then it it serves a
purpose one thing is quite often this
knight on c6 isn't a particularly great
piece as it blocks the sea porn and you
cannot use the C porn which can be very
useful in protecting d5 we see what like
is doing in this game just a couple of
moves and now c6 and this was the idea
by exchanging the six not
allow some is allowed to put the pawn
here and control d 5 with the porn which
is very useful this has a very solid
reputation on this line should be 2
rupee a doll very normal Luke see one
this is directed against d5 a black
would play d5 now then you have this
trick securing a plus for wide so d5 is
not that possible and this is why black
went back to UM f8 I'm not so sure that
I like this move myself cuz it looks it
gets a bit passive for black now in the
next couple of moves aronian played them
the very straightforward movie form just
clamping down on the d5 square and
preventing like from playing d5 here for
example let's say look let's look first
what how plenty played d6 here in fact
um it may be it is an idea to play the
original move Bishop c5 just back it
looks strange but ok let's say white
white has played a form and just a weak
entity foursquare maybe this is an idea
to activate the bishop and this is also
because this really looks like a useful
move that I question this Bishop f8 move
maybe like had ideas to stay more
flexible here and keep keep white
guessing a bit about the setup ok Bishop
f8 if I didn't go back he played t6 and
now this Bishop isn't a really an active
piece but um it's not a big deal for
black but it looks a bit passive ok h3
this is a good preparation Louth
covering g4 so that you can play Bishop
e3 without getting harassed by Knight g4
and a
yeah p5 was a positional threat that
white needs to attend to and now black
played rugby 8 intending to prepare me
five probably and King edge to this free
pass DF formals so why it's IDM is as
usual in this conformation which is
normally called the food winning setup
whites ideas to play on the King side
he's got the stable center and his
advances f4 maybe g4 f5 and the pawn
roller on the King side with all pieces
supporting him from behind and in fact I
think that white is slightly better in
this position it's maybe also a bit of a
matter of taste but I have played this
kind of setups for white for quite a
while and down I like them I think they
are especially from a practical point of
view easier to play for wide so now in
97 was played with the possible
re-routing of the night you should be
three activating this piece of it and
now a five yeah this is some any typical
positional muth securing those squares
especially c5 for the night but it's
still a massive move like cannot really
am alter the pawn structure now head
wide will get his advance on the
kingside in f 49 to c5 and Roxy to and
rook c2 is one of those moves that maybe
am wouldn't occur to lots of players but
it's a good move it prepares the others
roop shifts to f2 or g2 even and it
allows other things that we see in the
game and I bet that Aronian had those
kind of things in mind even you should
be 6 + f5 soba should be 6 mm not sure
this is such a successful move because I
five is probably a move that white plan
anyway Bishop back and Bishop e3 and
this is interesting this clears the way
for the rock
as mentioned and though you can root can
be used as the support piece for the
Jeep on it once but this Bishop also has
the idea to play Bishop to h5 and
putting pressure on f7 and this is a
really unusual idea and a very
interesting one don't see that too often
this kind of route to the to the week f7
square ok one how played b5 striving for
power to play but in fact it seems that
after this he's already in serious
trouble um it's difficult though to to
give him a decent recommendation the Sun
it's a slightly passive position where
white has an easy plan to make progress
by pushing the King side maybe I'm black
needed to do something I'm very direct
to to stop this one idea maybe this okay
but have a look at the game b5 it isn't
so obvious why this is bad but Aronian
makes it look really really bad it takes
on b5 like we captures and now this
mentioned who've bishop age five and
maybe this really am wasn't correctly
assessed by wang hao maybe the only
thought of the jeep own advance but this
is very concrete and very strong the
idea is sometimes just to sacrifice on
f7 and initiate a deadly attack we can
see for example with black would play
and we took but if we would play that
sales be form attacking the night 95 and
let's say Bishop a forum setting up this
pin winning the exchange but when exists
a not important at all because why it
has the Smasher check on f7 this is
really winning King takes and check and
even Bishop takes h6 and here black can
resign this is completely decisive
attack for example if black would grab
the rook
then white can can even take here and
this is really winning takes f6 and
you've got lv f seven threat and this is
some this is deadly no way if would like
to to defend him try to think of
something let's say here maybe to cover
f7 but check check yeah and this is oops
Queen h5 so the main threat and this is
also leading to checkmate black cannot
cannot even num OSS something better you
I look at five is better yeah this is
made him stronger yeah White has a super
dangerous attack with wish of age five
it seems to be decisive really this is
just a sample line with before but this
is such a throng threat I don't I don't
see a defense and I mean I don't see
defense it's not too hard an argument
but the computer also doesn't see
anything to defend this position yeah
one out took on c4 and turonian just
recaptured and now Bishop to e7 probably
intending this after all but wiped now
has more than one way to obtain a
decisive advantage he played one of them
took on c5 which an in general would be
a strategically horrible move to give up
your strong bishop against this night
but it's just winning for conclude
reasons recaptures and queen d 5 and
this is the concrete reason f7 is some
attacked and how do you defend this here
in fact um he also had an alternative
which was very strong as f6 also very
strong move this ship takes
teach you a point of this loop see to
move look here to cover d7 and then
Bishop g4 and black can also basically
resign him however aronian played this
move which is perfectly fine only moved
to defend f7 etrog f8 and now rope the
one attacking v7 only way to defend is
retreating this piece to this miserable
square blocking in the rook and now wyd
can win this pawn with tempo only move
and take a second point so what has
Jones just 12 points for absolutely
nothing and this is of course enough for
the world number three to win the game
like when going to be 6 no alternative
ready and he just exchanged and used the
sea porn to make further progress 95 is
so good and here I'm he had a good way
to reduce the material just taking
whoopsie form who takes and this h5
Bishop recaptures and now we get a
position where those pawns get exchanged
and at the end white is two extra points
and this is the main point actually a
big pressure on f7 this now check gets
played and here this is the point like
I'm not really Cavor have seven and
resigned actually here thought he played
one more move but there is no move
really f7 gets lost and while then a
three extra points and the sea point is
the loan would be very decisive or very
very dangerous and three bronzes simply
too much so very clean win for Aronian
um but somewhat strange play by one huh
but maybe he simply
underestimated this Bishop h5 which is
really yeah a bit a bit unusual I'm
looking forward here but they don't find
it it's a really am original maneuver
this this f3h five of seven all right so
a good game by Livan letting another win
and next one is kiwana against like my
this is a complicated game okay let me
let me let me load it somehow it's not
working now I know I got the game
Caruana against nakamura so d4 and now
can we are surprisingly once for Benoni
which is a very rare guest at top level
chess and it's not even a modern benoni
it's there's been only without this
movie 6 and the exchange on d5 your
white has some a huge range of
possibilities caruana goes for this
setup which is also a possibility
against the the modern benoni but here
it's a little bit different of course as
like hasn't played e6e 6 for example
cancels and this would now lead back to
the modern benoni that Nakamura place on
this immediately Bishop to see to yeah
this is because white wants to secure
the bishop against 95 that it down
cannot be exchanged 98 this plants this
night transform intending something like
this and play on the queenside we're
just um fairly logical now that white
hasn't done put up so much control over
b5 this is why goes a4 wants to prevent
this b5 move
and now Nakamura places the night on
reform which in fact in some cases isn't
even such a great idea it looks like a
great square but the night is not doing
so much but here I'm it always has an
eye on this bishop so it's probably
justified should be three andy sixx e6
after all it's probably really necessary
to free blacks position play the smooth
it's technically feasible here look and
now these six is not hanging because c 2
is also a tactile cannot cannot go here
and you lose a whole bunch of pieces
even so black uses a tactical trick to
play em play e6 Queen d2 yeah probably
white wants to increase the pressure
along the default Knight to f6 intending
this t he went for this yeah the
question should wider for prevented this
a move like a tree is certainly
something to consider to preserve this
bishop and the game this bishop was
taken couple of moves later exactly now
and now I'm yeah black actually netted
to the bishop pair and I think can be
rather satisfied with the opening result
it's got a very good Bishop on g7 and
defaults a potential hole which
immediately was occupied here white
needs to be cautious if he would play a
couple of routine moves without any
special idea of purpose then it could be
that like is it's better relatively
quickly he's got two bishops and those
strong dark squares the only problem is
he is not really a well-developed bishop
still on CH rukon head so if black is
given time
he will have a good position this is
also why Cara wanna play d5 now wants to
open up this Bishop especially and now
we've got some key traits and Bishop e7
muchas a good and strong move black cam
gives up a pawn for the moment but the
problem is he always has this counter
play on e5 and two bishops and he five
this weakness it's very very likely that
black will get the porn back on in fact
in the game this happened very quickly
2427 III and black guy got the pawn back
white had no way to keep this pawn on a
dark square for long so this is
understandable so yeah how to assess
this position black has got two bishops
and they're both very nicely positioned
I'm a problem for black is the pawn
structure it's got this region six pawn
which is a passed pawn but it's though
the richness and the king is slightly
slightly weakened White's pieces on the
other hand down and not so brilliant
either this bishop has some idea to go
to you for but it's very difficult to
imagine a stable night position before
but you've got two pieces for one square
this doesn't have too much so on I think
all in all black is a little bit more
comfortable here but it's not easy at
all he decided to regroup and black of
course keeps the bishops on you rather
retreats this instead of exchanging
which would be a big mistake so we are
from a couple of more moves which are
quite quite logical I would say all
right now we have a queen trade coming
h3 to cover the mate and black crosses
the Queen exchange so we have a pure end
game now and solve the net gain the
black is somewhat better
he's the only one to make any progress
the best the drug can offer some kind of
fortress-like setup that keeps the
position together I just continued a
couple of moves it's actually if you
would have for all I would have lots of
time of month I could analyze if there
was some some improvement for whites to
defend better the fact is after couple
of more moves in which the camera made
sensible good strengthening moves white
really AM was put on the on the
defensive bye well now let's um look a
couple of moments like gain space on the
on the kingside activated this piece but
it still doesn't look I'm too dramatic
however a couple of moves later check
here Bishop to c5 check and here exactly
in this position is that white actually
needed to take on c5 or breaking into
kingi to a similar though after king e
to look F form and you need to take
anyway on c5 is no way to to play it in
another another way like this losses to
Bishop c2 and this this bone is gone
some taking on c5 if you need to do it
anyway then you can also take him
something like this and now White has
managed to get rid of one of the bishops
but okay we also have absolutely all
pawns on light squares with the light
squared Bishop on the board and black
has also the light squared Bishop so
he's got this threat going a rookie
exchange would be rather welcome from
like am I supposed and black basically
has an extra porn also this is e born as
two black pawns keep
33 white bones black is significantly
better and has probably good winning
chances but this is what Kara wanna
probably I needed to do is very grim
though he played kinky and this meets
with the refutation maybe you also saw
this but hope that Nakamura I wouldn't
wouldn't see it on he speculated she
because the other continuation also
looks really grim so rock da check
Kinsey two and now in this position if
you have some time on your heads hence
then treat this as a puzzle and try to
find the best continuation from like it
it's not easy maybe the initial ideas as
a parent but it's not easy to work out
and calculate correctly so if you once
pause the video and have a longer look
what black should do now I'm going to
show it now like plate here is the very
strong move g-form of course taking no
no big choice wide needs to take with
the porn cannot go here check this is
one idea and now black as a follow-up
and of course you needed to see this as
well the follow-up is is the now rather
logical move h3 the point being if white
would capture the spawn then look f
eight wins instantly with the thread
rook takes f3 and white has no way to
prevent it he can player this move but
after repair form this is a deadly
pinned absolutely White has no way to
prevent the loss of at least PCM note
how strong those bishops are brilliant
so on if white would take on the h3 he's
lost and okay if you cannot take you
have a big problem he played the rube t1
and now after Luke f8
III like played h2 and here somehow like
it looks like some cheating has taken
place this H pawns in a way sneaked
around White's position and now is
threatening to yet to promote with the
move Bishop g1 and what what's was why
it's supposed to do we stop the born
with the root page one and now black
simply goes with Bishop g1 and this is
just a fun picture those two need two
pieces or units just kill this rook and
after kidney to like I'm where I played
that very simple very very simple
fashion but it's just effective and
winning he exchanged this and now its
invasion time for the king and here Kara
wanna resigned you can simply think of
this position as a position where black
has an extra exchange as this is simply
yeah one part of the the chessboard but
it simply cancelled cancelled each other
out and black and simply in weight or
invade even here and win the pawns it's
really a simply win and Kara wanna
resigned so really nice win for now
camera with this very pleasing finish of
g4 and h3 very nice motif like I'm Eliza
playing a really successful tournament
is on plus free now and dumb as some a
really good position in the tournament
yeah paltz had pulled some miracles and
earlier games where was really lost but
didn't didn't lose at the end and he is
really converting what is what is
getting in terms of chances so good
stuff nakamura winning okay so um which
game next let's go around against
kayaking and this I will do relatively
quickly
we have default by vision not too often
but the place deform once in a while
against kayak canoe can be relatively
sure that he's playing the queens and
yannis got one of the narrowest open
room opening repertoires of a top player
it's rather predictable and we've got
the petrol version system with a 3 i'm
jeong cactus has been played before this
check is to to lure black screen onto
some second-rate square with them it's
debatable this really is so great Quincy
to back and now black captured the sea
for porn which white obviously wants to
have back so plays III and here black
has tried the number of moves even roofs
that look relatively bizarre to me like
Bishop takes and three witches the the
main move that seems taking and we find
us the idea in fact and what kayaking
plate is very rare or even a novelty I
think it's almost a novelty played
Knight to g5 and this is completely
different from Bishop takes a 395 s and
now leads to a a simplified position and
the same almost by force 95 makes sense
gaining a tempo on the Queen and it
simply retreat it yeah this some bishop
needs to exchange not much choice
recaptures Bishop c4 and not like just
took on c3 retakes castles castle it's
97 yeah and white doesn't have much
choice he needs to take otherwise black
would take and give you a pretty ugly
double porn so why took Queen takes and
now we have a simplified position which
arises almost by force after this 95
idea in this simplified position white
will be better and probably for the
whole game but it's just one thing the
Seaport
that white can play em against and it's
a question if this really is enough to
get something tangible going we see that
after couple of natural moves white has
this pressure against c7 but black has
defensive resources he wants to exchange
one roof if possible and Dwight I'm
prevented if white would exchange it
would have been even less to to play for
gypsy form page six and now we come to
some period of peace shuffling it's
simply that it's difficult to to make
any kind of headway here low tides not
really doing too much yet here maybe
king of aid was a slight um yeah in
accuracy with bushy now been even able
to play before this is simply because
I'm after taking like you're not capture
now because there's d8 hanging and play
like should have played something that
keeps this look projected and this now
looks really uncomfortable because we
see that what even gets to be five with
upon and now has even fixed weakness on
c7 and the point is you can look at this
also with the computer and it gives
white a very substantial advantage and
of course if you look at this you have
no doubt that white is better but how do
you actually make progress to get to
something something concrete here it's
not at all easy in fact are not try it
but he
made absolutely no progress he invaded
with the Queen on the 7th year but black
guy could defend with Bishop a aid of
course for black guy this is some really
unattractive grovel this this whole game
but he somehow got into this and now
needs to defend this position and in
fact it doesn't look like white can do
so much of the couple of moves black
managed to play c6 and get rid of this
weakness and in fact Allen down rather
quickly I'm took on c6 and combined this
with the draw offer yeah in fact them
you could play on in this position it's
not like the complete super debt draw
that you sometimes he but i'm pretty
sure that fishy was pretty disappointed
that he didn't really get got something
going against this rather passive setup
and now that black has some relieved
himself of this weakness um it's
probably relatively easy to to hold this
yeah a bit of disappointed
disappointment as why was really looking
looking good him and thus in this game
but it didn't seem to be enough okay
next game is is yeah let's have a look
at how crucial against who you form and
we got a Sicilian and the verse given
Ian yeah guess nowadays on in tournament
practice because of G for the carrots
attack which I Krishna actually played
he didn't play Bishop e2 lochia played
against when really not exactly the same
position but the setup white could have
played them he could have played them in
a similar way but she for some known as
the sharpest approach against given
again age six is the main line stopping
the further advance now each form
it's again the sharpest move and e5 and
I must admit I actually never have seen
this movie 5 p.m. and i know that this
is possible with without the h pawn
moves and this leads to some technical
sequences which are not working now but
i really don't know the the theory i
didn't look it up we have a pretty
unusual position with the knights on c3
and d3 here it's really unusual in the
keris attack there should be six and
nine twenty-five looks down normal
placing this in the center and black
decided to get rid of one night and put
this on e7 and after couple of more
moves let's play this moves Queenie to
Bishop g7 25 I'm not sure if the Queen
exchange is such a great idea but let's
have a look what is what's happening 97
looks it we should be formed yeah I
wanted to get to this position um we see
that we have an imbalance in terms of
the pawn structure black has got form
again three on the King side so it's
clear that black should try to advance
on this flank and on the other hand
white is got four against three but he
is somewhat behind in advancing the
pawns um and therefore i'm not quite
sure who is better in this position like
no I right now went age five this is
really am collecting move against the
play on the kingside he wants to make f5
less attractive but we found place this
quite nicely I think you should played
Bishop f6 and now we group this Bishop
to g5 on g7 it didn't have much scope on
g5 it's it's it's there nicely
controlling some squares on this
diagonal
and has activated itself nicely and
Blake still sf5 as a possibility later
got 93 p6 good support move and white
now took on c5 he took this chance to
take now because I'm here if black would
take with the rook then ninety form this
is a possibility to to simplify the
position however I mean this is playable
for black she took with the B porn which
seems fine as well it's a bit more more
interesting maybe two to play in this
way now to you for Andrew create needed
to cover d6 and now Wyatt took on g6 I'm
not sure if this is such a great idea to
be honest maybe why should should stay
like would be three or something some
some move like this yeah f5 still maybe
not exactly what d3 all I don't like to
open this position up before black
stroke but maybe there wasn't really
something better well it took and
recapture now legs got the effort to
work with Luke h3y a wide wants to get
some activity for the rook look a form
attacking and he sacrificed the spawn
but in return got on the 7th rank and
now it gets tactical this is saying both
pieces sighing and I think wyd really
misjudged this position on a bit as this
long tactical sequence here or exchange
sequence such as rather force this
actually seems to favor black and this
is due to the fact that blacks king is
some playing actively and if this porn
falls then there there are two our
passports immediately
the e porn and the Jeep on and in fact
they're supported by the king so what
this seems to be the most important
factor here check king to f5 rookie to
and covering this pond G for it here is
a critical position here wider probably
needed to play a form getting quickly
something in terms of counter play on
the queenside what he did is he played
c3 and now like had direct win a
tactical win which however wasn't easy
at all with probably very little time on
the clock we see the clock time cm of
course um she didn't overstep the time
limit so a minus is nonsense but she was
very long time probably he a black hood
playbook h8 would be very strong if
white would take now then there's rook
age two and this capture and after this
Jeep one simply promotes I mean it white
cannot really prevent it to the spawn
will promote um but it wasn't easy she
played them kingi fire first and after
rookie to she got the right idea rook to
f8 this is rather similar actually the
other thing was just a little bit more
forcing why takes takes on F to check
and why it gets upon mech so black is
actually at the moment porn down but
it's not a matter of quantity about of
quality this oops this Jeep on is very
strong we got five III and we got some
repetitions with little time on the
clock but now black goes forward yeah
here it was possible to prevent one roof
sir to be exchanged and we've got got
this and now the after this Gigi phone
is ready to roll and did and once a
cheap shot autumn
neat trick using the advanced porn yeah
and here wyd resigned this route de five
is the nah the last nice touch let's say
check here check and this this is
checkmate threatenings of my tags check
but check me his checkmate and this was
wasn't BOS couldn't be prevented white
would take and go here black of course
simply can push the air phone and get a
new queen to win so yeah the second win
for will your fun great great stuff
she's actually playing a rather good
tournament I mean it looks always
strange if you look at the bottom at of
the cross table and okay she's not doing
too well whatever but she's won two
games and now she's actually winning
rating points she's really a huge
underdog in this tournament even with
the 26 rating so on good stuff
Winningham another game here on against
harikrishnan alright so the next game
I'm going to show it's a zoo cool off
against lake home we have some sort of
thematic tournament here with the zocalo
playing and the Reuben sternum so with
wide and be 45 is black it seems like
seems like this way okay we've got
another line of the Rubenstein and this
is the cup of line probably a.m. it's
called the cap of line because Karpov is
the main or was the main um player to
promote this setup all fairly logical
normal stuff and this is similar to a
game of an earlier round
this was so cool off against hmm long
howl I'm not quite sure we had the curl
of had this before on this line okay he
am prepared the typical battery against
the age seven so with this kind of
intentions whoopsie 8th route 19 h 5 so
that age five is also fairly typical
move to initiate exchanges and of course
the the normal reaction here would be 4y
to maybe just take night takes and then
it continues like don't know 95 yeah one
night maybe this but 19 f4 could be it
could be an answer here but this would
be fairly normal and probably leading to
some sort of equal position however
Sokolov camera cam came up with an
interesting idea and this is quincy to
let threaten may tiem becos answer was
g6 and the instant answer okay you could
say okay what else but in fact on the
strange-looking move f5 could be
considered it's it looks very weird but
it's not losing instantly of course it
looks bad but it's not so bad black has
this idea okay but g6 was played and
this actually is a move if you play this
instantly this clearly hints at some
home preparation because of course
there's one move that what should
consider now and in fact sokoloff even
played it he played rook takes the 6th
rook sacrifice this means that this was
probably a piece of preparation by lake
home because if you play g6 instantly
you knew beforehand that this should be
okay for you you needed to really check
this before you allow this sacrifice
first the easy point if
I could take check check check Nate then
it's um yeah early afternoon coffee but
you've lost the game so black cannot
take so I was this a blunder giving away
the spawn and allowing this threat in
fact black plays Knight f4 here and he
did so rather quickly and this is a
really good move it protect g6 it
attacks e6 and it has a number of
technical implications that can be for
why it's really annoying if white for
example would just retreat just to look
at okay h4 sayings makes no sense let's
say white would take okay now it takes
yeah and now the rookwood move let's say
you move to e1 then black can simply
take play this with Queen g5 as a
possibility also night XD force in the
position and simply white is clearly
were cm this means Bishop takes the
seminoles not really great so what can
you do you need to move the rook and h4
is hanging so it's difficult you could
play a rupee form attacking this night
but this allows night to be formed and
now we see that the b7 the bishop is
attacking the rook so wyd lose this
material whatever you you do yeah it's
simply not the Colossus tournament he
needed to exchange sec on me 7 and play
Queen d2 this was the relatively best
way to play but after g5 it seems that
white is in big trouble if he would take
on g5 which looks pretty good at first
sight um black head has at least this
answer leading to a good position if
white would retreat
then black hood check in this way we
gain the peace and stays with an extra
exchange and no our problems in any way
so g5 is really a problem white try
tonight if I've to confuse matters but
now it was time for liquid to to think
about all this you probably left his
preparation and after while he played 96
and this is good good and simple really
right took we capture and black simply
is the one attacking and this is the
problem White has no attack it's a
exchange down and yea even black is the
one with the active play along the long
diagonal we should retreat it and just
takes on g2 and this is not only
grabbing a pawn but also preparing moves
like nine th for to f3 for example
Quincy to ok at least try with the maid
threat but ok black simply takes
somebody takes this away and cara's g6
we should be fine Queen f7 a three gap
this is some an idea but like just
played them night to aid form and yeah
the final tribe was Bishop a to now
setting up the spin but liquid more than
one good reply but he decided for the
very direct this is even play quite
irritated I've crossed g6 sg6 discovered
I was completely irritated by Queen a to
Queen g6 but of course this night is
discovering yeah Queen takes a two was
my cousins and the point being if wide
recaptures then abs of course this first
rook takes e2 and black is winning group
takes
Knight f3 were the really really big
check and black will win even more
material now let's sing king here you
should check check and king g to check
nightly one shake Nets rook so it
continues to be a simply horrific
tournament for physical off no losing
again and yeah it's somehow it's yeah I
think this was really interesting play
move with rookie six but as maybe his
play in this tournament is some are
according to some German figure of
speech where we sometimes say that yeah
first we had no luck and then we even
got bad luck maybe not the best
translation but it's it's maybe a
fitting description for a phone for his
player all right I got all games besides
of course cards and against la me which
also incidentally was the longest game
of the round and this is pretty normal
for Magnus he simply has those marathon
games quite often so we've got a care
account and just 92 yeah Margaret's
place all opening so cannot really say
something like this is one of his
favorites or something he plays all
lines but of course you could expect the
CARICOM by Lao me who played this all
tournament heey Bishop c4 this is a
sideline but not a bad one the main move
of course is h4 h5 this kind of setup
but this intends to develop the night
later to air form in this way 9f form
yeah here like the main continuation is
to play on Bishop 26 and this is a
fairly solid for black and in fact this
also the recommendation that I'm I made
in a video that I produce for eyes to
see in German language well I do a black
repertoire in
during the caro-kann they have this
Bishop p6 move on but allow me played
something else and he played b5 and this
seems to be a novelty on maybe one game
that I found don't remember exactly but
it's a super rare move so it's a case of
you know that Magnus going to play some
new move at some point some surprise and
this is the case of get your surprising
first but it's not it's not a revelation
or something you can play this but it's
so not especially great there should be
69 f4 yet here on this position in this
position type even a black has a choice
he can let white capture on g6 or take
on our forum in fact here black needs to
reckon with F with h4 h5 and therefore
it's probably necessary to take on air
form and he did this instantly but this
also means you've just given sorry this
also means that you just have given them
probably best tactic technical player on
earth given the bishop pair and yeah i'm
not sure if you really want to do that
of course it's very tricky against him
anyway whatever you do but it somehow
feels like long-suffering if you give
him two bishops in a fairly quiet
position ok see for this is an
interesting choice and very
straightforward white could also
consider to play slow moves like c3
first or a four or something but c4 is
very direct this some invites the
capture and this is probably the best
move awesome and now we have them an
opening of the position where the C porn
is a potential weakness in fact I think
I'm le'me defended rather rather well
let's just put a couple of my moves on
the more they're all
pretty young pretty normal looking m3
yep this covers some important squares
age 692 we rooting the snide 927 drop
back and this is an important moment 'if
I've this is important because it
changes the pawn structure in fact him
maybe he should have been more yeah
should have employed sit and wait
strategy and just do nothing like let's
say queen bee seven and a five or
something i'm not quite sure about the
coke weed move but simply keep the paw
information as it as it is at the moment
and the c5 move probably wasn't a great
idea i understand that he probably am
and didn't have enough patience to
defend this this position against cards
but i think if I've helps wide because
it further opens the position Abdi for
this isolated pawn yeah was a weakness
and now what gets rid of it b3 quite
move that strong move improving on the
queenside and asking black what are you
going to do with the e pond and he went
queen bee six and Knight c3 against
strong first you think all right what
about this move like an can just take
here here it's important that white is
able to play Knight a form um this was a
played in the game is just a line 9 a-4
has the capture check here with check
gives black some activity the d3 porn
supported by the bishop is some some
source of counter play you don't want
that but 9 a-4 is strong this was played
but I'm talking about is
that this move is stronger is stronger
Queen will need to move and then you
just take it and now we see why it still
has got the two bishops but the DNT porn
have been exchanged and this must be in
Wyatt's favor d for was a potentially
week porn while he six was a perfect
part of black spot skeleton yeah what is
clearly better with the two bishops and
the weakness on the C file this was pawn
in the game he played Knight f6 which
leads to a similar structure takes and
now we see black managers manage to
exchange against d porn and this is just
favorable for white maybe he just wanted
to get get rid of four more pieces to
simplify but then it I think it's a
positive development for y to the sixth
change queen bank and well just
improving further getting the Queen out
of the D farm and getting this into the
position yeah so how does white make
progress now it's not not easy at all h4
this is a very good move and something
you need to yeah try to remember that
often push us off the flank pawns can be
a good a good way to improve your
position what what is why it's IDM the
idea is to maybe play Queen to g3
looking at this g7 porn and threatening
age five and with those pawn moves you
can often in a way tickle your opponent
to make more weaknesses it's a good move
that is that it's worth remembering in
it's just a sample position but very
often those flank pawn moves are
important to create further weaknesses
black played f6 you treat it and create
a king
seven and now a count oak and this is a
remarkable decision I mean I'm pretty
sure of course I'm by far the weaker
player but I wouldn't i probably
wouldn't take on d5 i simply would love
my two bishops too much and would try to
continue playing with those pieces so
maybe is that say Bishop c5 or look do
you wanna try to improve the position
further maybe em prepare something on
the King side I don't know what council
is very concrete he just took 95 and
done since I've got two points if black
would take with the sea porn then White
has the very strong move h5 look the
h-bond it's a useful pawn if black would
take now then there's Queen edge for
with the tempo retreats and Ruby 7 and
this is the problem with the pawn
recapture it immediately opens up the
seventh-ranked and now the thread Queen
takes f6 or Bishop takes f6 black is
completely busted group g80 we eat we
seven and this is just over like what
let's let's play silly move takes yeah
then there's inches one check check
check neat and the mate so this is after
right after this capture black guy took
with the rook and not with the porn and
after taking with the rook it's simply
upon Magnus oh just traded his bishop
pair for an extra porn and now continues
to bright this position it's a hell no
it doesn't look like so much but he
manages after 12 to make some progress
and in fact I'm honest it would be
rather interesting to to look at this in
depth but i'm already on move
on minute 71 of this video and this
continues for about 30 moves it's it's
simply too much to ask to do detailed
analysis iam he slowly but steadily Jake
some progress in this check even with
the Queen's off and um yeah one looking
pair of roots down but white is got got
done a passed pawn yeah the position is
clearly better for white and teeth just
press this on now it gets gets
interesting again because he needed to
really exactly calculate that blacks
counterplay is not good enough Bishop f8
Luke takes on a two and king of fraud
this is not too difficult but still very
strong rook takes you seven or
threatened with them really hit deadly
deadly check on g7 black needs to make
some space like this check and retreated
all the way back now those pawns are
weakened he immediately goes to to win
this pawn but you always need to take
into account that there's this a pawn
whoopsie to and he just took and you
need to really calculate this correctly
it looks a bit unnatural all this here
wizard elevate but there is simply
nothing to give this check but why just
retreats and there's no way to make use
of this this Bishop position so let's
say this white can just play this
with the 10-point intent Bishop g7 check
so a three is what was played and now
rue k7 was just some the human move firm
to play in fact that there was an
alternative what I need to need to have
a look at my analysis there was a really
strange alternative in this position
that I i forgot about but I know that it
was when you played rukka 87 just give
me a second him yeah okay seven he had
the the move Bishop to c5 which looks
really weird for for human the ideas
after a two to play Bishop deform and of
course this over this looks at the a1
square so cannot promote but this is a
very unusual piece on the long diagonal
and it really seems that there's no way
for black to make use of this rather
weird setup let's say here there should
be five and it's all protected Black has
really no no chance to to do something
and white next move will be Rick a seven
and then the G porn would would be
pushed plus a king king or discovered
checks so this was even a bit stronger
but it looks on it looks rather
unnatural to play this way okay seven is
completely okay of course a to ng three
just keeping the spawn and improving
afterwards give this check and white
brings the the bishop back to help now
the bishop covers this and you always
needed to calculate this that this pawn
is not suddenly becoming the winner for
black but he doesn't really make any
calculation
eggs and those simplified positions and
after okay one in fact now me resigned
yeah it could have continued for for a
while but well what what can you do this
guy's play like like a machine in those
positions making almost no mistakes so
I'm like resigned at Carson and now is
on eight out of ten which means some
he's on track on maybe equalizing or
even improving on his power off some
1999 record result in bike when he
scored 10 out of 13 which is really a
brilliant result + 7 7 wins and six
drawers if you don't lose the game and
yeah well Magnus is may be able to
repeat this if he would make two out of
three in the last three rounds he would
equal the score maybe there's even more
puzzle you never know with them alright
thanks for watching this video it's been
quite long and it's already really late
iam and so I hope I didn't make too many
silly mistakes and hope I also didn't
forget a game this seems to happen i
think i have the more yeah thanks for
watching i'll be back with the video on
maybe on friday on saturday morning um
there's no round on Thursday so new
games will be played on friday and i'm
not sure if i'll be able to make a video
on friday maybe it will become only a
maybe it will be possible only on
saturday for me to to do this thanks for
watching and I'll be back soon